public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président de debout la france nicolas
dupont aignan est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir en soi et merci d'être
avec nous à ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp avec les échos et radio
classique l'actualité économique et
industriel vous donne l'occasion de
réagir de bondir même et j'ai envie de
dire nicolas dupont aignan vous
répondrai donc à trois grandes questions
aujourd'hui un la politique mise en
oeuvre avec le budget 2010 8 aces une
politique pour tous les français comme
le dit l'exécutif jours et on vous
répondrez à jean francis pécresse 2 la
sorbonne après l'acropole
enfin une ambition pour l'europe mickels
à metz vous interrogera sur le discours
volontariste du chef de l'état enfin
trois avec qui est ce que vous avez
poursuivre votre aventure politique
après votre pas de deux avec marine le
pen vous le dirai tout à l'heure à
guillaume dos dames est d'abord une
toute première question d'actualité
[Musique]
et bien sûr le grand meccano industriel
et capitalistique et autour d' alstom
siemens et des chantiers navals stx
bruno lemaire défend sur les sites
concernés
aujourd'hui et demain la garantie pour
les salariés français 1 pour leur emploi
notamment le ministre de l'économie a
lancé aujourd'hui à saint nazaire mais
c'était également valable pour alstom il
l'a dit l'union fait la force il demande
donc aux salariés français d'être
confiants pourquoi ne pas être confiant
sachant qu effectivement l'union fait la
force
mais c'est pas une union c'est une
absorption c'est un acte de haute
trahison industriels et national moi je
suis pour une union style airbus belle
idée que de faire un airbus ferroviaire
mais airbus
si vous regardez comment ça c'est fait
c'est une base d'égalité c'est à 11%
d'actionnariat allemand 11% français des
entreprises en plus part de l'état et
puis après des entreprises c'est une
aventure collective
c'est pas le sabordage part des
autorités politiques françaises de leur
propre outil industriel valeur du coin
haute trahison oui je fais mon âge c'est
très grave
vous allez parler du patriotisme
solidement mais je dis simplement on ne
fera pas l'europe sur la destruction
d'un pays ce qui se passe sur l'affairé
alsthom relèvera d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire
je la demande mais il vous faut des
alliés nationale d'abord la gauche tous
les élus et retour déjà où les élus qui
n'accepte pas que des autorités
politiques ça bord de leur propre pays
parce que sur alstom soyons précis
alstom ferroviaire a plus de commandes
que siemens ferroviaire beaucoup plus
est on le sait le chiffre d'affaires est
aussi important sinon supérieur et
surtout les brevets l' avance
technologique française c'est un des
points d'appui fondamental de l'avenir
il n'y avait aucune raison de donner 51
% 50 % + 1 à siemens
quand vous dépouiller avions par exemple
vous visez qui des religions les chars
de l'e40 la banque rothschild comme par
hasard comme par hasard qui officie
elle l'a fait sur alstom avec general
electric car ce qui est insupportable
dans cette affaire c'est qu'on peut
commettre une erreur une fois mais on a
des exemples précis il ya eu technip qui
nous a été vendu comme l'union fait la
force
au bout de six mois les américains
avaient les deux tiers du conseil
d'administration alors technip était
plus important que l'entreprise
américaine
il ya eu alcatel qui a été bradée chez
nokia et maintenant monsieur macron
pleurent misère devant les licenciements
mais vous savez il ya eu il ya eu
lafarge qui a été bradée avec
l'entreprise sioniste
alstom énergie oui ça fait pas beaucoup
alors à propos d'un soutien à nos
énergies on a le droit de réagir quand
même un propos d'alstom nrg à chaque
fois à presque chaque fois la banque
rothschild qui avec la complicité de
certains dirigeants et la faiblesse de
l'état accepte ce sacrifice industriels
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'europe
soyons clairs oui au partenariat
européen mais pas avec la domination
d'une entreprise sur une autre alors
vous êtes rejoints par arnaud montebourg
dans une tribune au monde cet après midi
et il cite le cas d'alstom énergie
effectivement qui a été vendue à
l'américain general electric et il parle
lui en s'abritant derrière la justice
américaine des dirigeants corrompus
d'alstom vous aller jusque là
aujourd'hui vous à l'exception
aujourd'hui puisque vous parlez de
saint-sever aux trahisons et sous dans
les yvelines dirigeants la bst a aussi
de corruption souvenez-vous corruption
souvenez vous qu on nous avait dit au
moment du mariage avec general electric
monsieur macro ministre de l'économie
nous avaient dit les 12 milliards reçus
vont fortifier le pôle ferroviaire où
sont passés ces sommes est bien dans des
stocks options pour les principaux
dirigeants de cette société qui après
avoir vendu l'outil de travail à general
electric qui n'a pas respecté ses
promesses et qui licencient maintenant
où est passé cet argent
pire dans le deal qui vient d'être signé
avec siemens
les coentreprises qu'on nous avait
promis qu'ils sont vitales pour
l'énergie nucléaire
les coentreprises fait entre alstom et
général electric les deux milliards 5
vont être obtenue comment on va les
abandonner au mépris des promesses de
monsieur macro min
des finances aurait pu aller connexion
enrichissement en tout cas
enrichissement personnel avec des stock
options indus et je le dis faiblesse de
l'état alors sur radio classique et
jacques minutes et j'ajoute je pèse mes
mots
j'ajoute qu'il n'est pas normal qu'une
grande banque dans laquelle a travaillé
le président de la république organise
ce démantèlement de notre industrie
je ne l'accepterai jamais alors sur
radio classique en tous les cas le
président béchir devra en répondre
d'accord alors le patron d'alstom à
monsieur poupart-lafarge déclaré ce
matin sur radio classique que ceux qui
critiquent le patriotisme manque de
patriotisme se trompe c'est un
patriotisme mal placée dit il le
patriotisme aujourd'hui il veut être
européen ces nouvelles souveraineté mais
face aux halles haschich face aux états
unis j ch
eh bien pourquoi pas un bel airbus
ferroviaire avec une parité comme
l'avait fait d'ailleurs je crois c'est
georges pompidou sur les moteurs d'avion
safran c'était snecma à l'époque il y
avait une entreprise américaine une
entreprise française
on a créé une coentreprise égalité
égalité
j'ajoute je demande au président
d'alstom ferroviaire est ce qu'il est
prêt à renoncer à ses stock options
est ce qu'il est prêt à mettre sur la
table
ainsi que les dirigeants d'alstom
énergie ce qu'ils ont touché pour vendre
pour vendre pour brader un outil
industriel français où nous sommes dans
les meilleurs du monde
parce que ce qui est en cause c'est pas
de refuser les partenariats
il faut des partenariats et de toute
façon à partir du moment où il avait
sabordé alstom énergie on sait très bien
qu alstom ferroviaire ne pouvait pas
travailler seuls ce que je demande c'est
que l'état le gouvernement et une
politique industrielle qui veille à la
défense en hausse à tout dernier point
puisque votre directeur de cabinet
jean philippe tanguy a publié un tweet
insultant pour emmanuel macron il l'a
retirée depuis
il la menace que je lui ai demandé il
avait traité à je le dis quand même
village et très le chef de l'état
d'ordures dans une paria
parce que moi je parlerai jamais du chef
de l'état comme ça et pas chez nous donc
je lui dis mais je maintiens qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à avoir des
licenciements dans notre pays
dans les entreprises on est les
meilleurs parce que l'autorité politique
ne les défend pas on n'est pas normal
j'insiste sur un point
oui nous avions un grand conglomérat
alstom il reste plus rien alors qu
hitachi japonais general electric
américain et siemens sont survivants eh
bien je vais vous dire c'est parce que
les autorités politiques françaises ont
abandonné la suite tout de suite avec
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
éditorialiste aux échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jean francis bonsoir michel
bonsoir nicolaon soir union est ce que
le projet de budget 2010 8 présenté hier
par le gouvernement est ce que c'est un
projet de budget pour tous les français
ou est ce que c'est un budget pour
quelques-uns pour les plus aisés comme
le dit la gauche mais bien sûr c'est un
budget mais c'est même pas pour les plus
aisés c'est un budget pour les super
riches ne même pas ceux qui créent parce
qu' il peut y avoir des gens qui est des
moyens en france
et moi je suis pour l'initiative privée
je suis pour que ceux qui veulent gagner
puisse gagner de l'argent mais là c'est
pas ça c'est un budget de remerciement
pour campagne électorale 5 milliards à
peu près pour les plus fortunés des
fortunés parce que même des gens qui ont
des biens immobiliers vont continuer à
payer les sf mais en revanche ceux qui
sont de la finance vont être exonérés
donc c'est le sait le budget le plus
provocateur pour les français qui existe
une taxe sur le capital réduite à 30 %
qui fait que pire des gens qu un petit
capital vont devoir payer plus ou moins
gros vont payer deux fois moins et un
tour de passe passe est incroyable pour
les plus modestes ou les classes
moyennes où on leur fait croire qu'on va
leur donner de l'argent baisse de la th
augmentation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé mais qui est compensée par la
hausse de la csg la suppression de l'apl
la réduction d'apl la suppression des
emplois aidés la hausse du diesel
la hausse du tabac etc donc ça veut dire
que quand il s'agit de la superclasse
financières françaises
alors là c'est tapis rouge et quand il
s'agit des français dans leur grande
masse c'est on vous donne on fait
semblant de vous donner quelque chose et
on vous le reprend moi je ne suis pas
hostile à des mesures d'incitation à la
création de richesses en france il en
faut mais je suis scandalisé par ce
budget vous voudriez taxer plus le
capital non plus la formule non ça mais
si sessegnon et entraînant non c'est pas
moi j'ai pas compris alors beaucoup d
une harmonisation européenne javert est
posée aux normes européennes ont pas
toutes arrivées encore en matière de
piges avait proposé une mesure sein
pendant la présidentielle qui était une
exonération du sf
lorsque les fonds s'investissait en
france
j'avais proposé une baisse de l'impôt
sur les sociétés pour les pme lorsque
les entreprises réinvestissent est le
bénéfice en france
je ne suis pas hostile parce que il faut
inciter à la création de richesses en
france et c'est ma différence avec la
gauche je suis favorable à des mesures
d'incitation fiscale et de baisse
fiscale mais je veux que ces baisses
fiscales et j'ai toujours demandé
qu'elles soient conditionnées à
l'investissement dans notre pays car on
va le voir très vite
ce n'est pas en donnant des milliards à
une super classe qui valait l'investir
ailleurs qu'on va résoudre les problèmes
et l'emploi cette super classe
précisément elles valent que milliers de
les reverser cet argent ailleurs parce
qu'il ya une taxation
oui quel juge et qui est beaucoup plus
élevé en france qu'elle ne les lis
ailleurs est ce que le fait que ce que
fait le gouvernement au fond c'est de
dire voilà il ya un effet de
ruissellement sur l'économie française
c'est à dire qu'on va alléger la
taxation sur les plus riches pour qu'il
revienne en france il reste en france
est une des rares et si on les dans
l'économie française est ce que vous ai
compris
vous ne partagez pas du tout surpris je
pense qu'il faut une baisse oui parce
que notre niveau de fiscalité est trop
élevé pour les créateurs de richesse
donc je ne suis pas comme monsieur
mélenchon pour taxer au contraire mais
je demande que cette baisse favorise en
priorité les pme ce qui est plus le cas
et je demande à ce que cette baisse soit
conditionnée à l'investissement en
france et je voudrais vous faire une
remarque ce qu'est ce qui est
extravagant dans ce projet de budget et
vous l'avez pas mis dans votre journal
et il ya une erreur dans votre journal
et je voudrais vous puissiez la corriger
dans une prochaine édition
c'est que le cic eu l' avantage pour les
entreprises les pme va être réduit
l'année prochaine
si ces noms dans le journal ce
maintenant dans ce journal ya une erreur
dans votre journal à 20 et est classé
dans % en 2017
oui il passe de 6 à ces bruits mais
l'année prochaine en 2010 huit mois j'ai
dû jay passe de 7 à 6 c'est un tout
petit peu un tout petit peu l'accès y
passe de 6 à 7 % en 2017 mais en 2018 il
revient à 6 exactement
c'est dommage parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
chefs de pme qui sont lecteurs des échos
au pouvoir qu'à une mg siegler quand ils
vont voir que ce gouvernement ils ne
savent pas ils n'ont pas été informés ce
matin dans votre journal que ce
gouvernement qui se dit pro business a
réduit la baisse d'impôt sur les pme
c'est à dire que d'un côté pour les
copains banquiers eux quelques centaines
de personnes de la finance
internationale
cadeau milliards et de l'autre nos
patrons de pme vont avoir moins de
baisse de charges et quand même
extravagant et donc c'est là où je suis
en désaccord
moi je veux des baisses de charges sur
les patrons de pme sur ceux qui créent
et qui investissent dans notre pays
quand vous parle toujours de manuel
mâcon le coc lui l'ami des banquiers il
est disqualifié pour être président
comme il était banquier a en tout cas il
renvoie l'ascenseur à ceux qui ont
financé sa campagne à cette oligarchie à
cette super classe et il va faire
souffrir les français comme jamais je ne
l'accepté pas c'est un gigantesque
manipulateur manipulateur sur la sphère
alstom qu'on fait passer pour un dossier
européen alors que c'est une prise de
pouvoir de siemens manipulateur sur la
création d'entreprise
alors que les impôts sur les charges sur
les pme vont augmenter l'année prochaine
je n'accepte pas ces manipulations alors
on va écouter son ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire qui lui considère que
cette politique mise à l'oeuvre à
travers le budget 2010 8 est bel et bien
une politique pour tous on écoute bruno
le maire le ministre de l'économie
nous voulons que ces transformations
économiques que ce soutien à
l'innovation en investissement à la
création d'emplois puissent profiter à
tous les français
c'est un budget pour tous les français
qui prend en compte les difficultés des
uns et des autres qui engage dès 2018
l'allègement de la taxe d'habitation qui
engage une baisse d'impôts de l'ordre de
10 milliards d'euros pour l'année
prochaine qui veut faire attention aux
plus fragiles à chaud qui sont le plus
en difficulté vous savez moi j'ai la
vérité des chiffres
je sais faire des calculs et et avant de
venir j'ai fait des additions ce qu'en
fait je crois que le ministre de
l'économie s'est pas compter alors il
fait un cadeau sur la taxe d'habitation
il fait un cadeau et c'est bien parce
que je l'avais proposé sur l'allocation
adulte handicapé et c'est nécessaire et
il fait une baisse de charges sociales
sur les salariés
on pourrait s'en réjouir et je m'en
réjouirai honnêtement si ce qui la
donnaient dans une poche n'était pas
repris dans l'autre et quand je fais des
calculs 1 milliards 7 sur les apl qui
vont être gagné ça veut dire que des
français modestes qui sont au seuil de
pauvreté et qui ont une petite aide au
logement qui permet de survivre je le
vois dans ma ville vont être assassiné
un milliard sept attendez la suite un
milliard sur les emplois aidés qui
permettent à des personnes qui étaient
au rsa de retravailler vont être
supprimés eu 22 milliards de cg sur nos
retraités 22 milliards 3,5 milliards sur
la fiscalité écologique qui va augmenter
la facture du gazole du gaz et de
l'essence pour aller travailler et cela
fait 28 sept
or les cadeaux ses 24,5 il va alourdir
sur les ménages français de 4 milliards
puisque la finalité une seule partie des
baisses d'impôts globalement l'année
normalement baisses d'impôts de 2017
quelles sont elles sont de 7 milliards
d'euros ou parce que vous comptez la
haute finance n'a l'impression à brouter
les sages en milliards d'entendre
question en ce1 soumise au fond c'est ça
du tout trets est très étonnante voodoo
non quand on emballe caricature vous
savez moi je ne veux pas la sueur
fiscalité de la france a soumises et de
monsieur mélenchon je suis convaincu
qu'il faut une politique pour 2 pén aux
pme qui investissent en france ce que je
conteste dans ce gouvernement c'est que
l'argent qu'il va dépenser ne va pas
servir à produire en france mais qu'est
ce que vous en savez on le sait très
bien
le risque il n'y a aucun mécanisme
incitatif et que les taxes sur les
petites entreprises ont augmenté
donc moi j'aimerais qu'on m'explique
comment on va produire en france
quand d'un côté e.on reprend d'une main
ce qu'on a donné aux français donc ils
vont pas pouvoir consommer plus puisque
ils reprennent autant d'une main que
l'eau don mais la seule cliente est la
transformation du cic en baisse de
charge et pas cette année c'est dans les
dix huit semaines seulement 7 en 2019
la wii mais j'attendais a été une
revendication pas fait patronat mais ils
ne font pas leur année élevé le patronat
qui le met le monde sait cela mais s'ils
le font bien
non on va le faire en 2010 n'en attendez
attendez 2018
emmanuel macron s'était engagé là dessus
ils ont renoncé et ils augmentent
déportés d'un an louis en deux matches
dans des devoirs attendez de voir en
fait le patronat les patrons de pme sont
les grands cocus de ce budget si je peux
me permettre cette expression un peu
vulgaire c'est à dire que ce budget est
fait pour la grande finance
internationale pour les copains j'espère
qu'ils ne sont pas qu'aucun est en tout
cas sans doute laissé entendre
lourdement comme la main vous êtes
jaloux oui mais c'est grave
vous n'êtes jamais content en fait mais
je suis pas jamais content c'est je
voudrais que mon pays ça sort j'ai
l'impression que vous n'êtes jamais
content nature esthétique ni sur alstom
ni sur le bas valais oms la chute la
content de voir radier notre radio les
mesures que ces régions excusez moi
monsieur pécresse revenir là dessus
moi vous savez s'il y avait des mesures
qui permettent de produire en france et
rapatrier des productions de relocaliser
et d'offrir du boulot à nos salariés
vous êtes peut-être vu que le chômage
avait augmenté depuis le début d'année
en tous les cas pour ambition en une
notion sais pas c'est aussi là on verra
ce que ça donne dernière question
résidents de région aujourd'hui ont
claqué la porte de la conférence des
territoires sont pas compris mais voyons
pas content non plus parce qu'il me
protestent contre une baisse de dotation
de 4
150 millions d'euros on a l'impression
que les efforts c'est toujours pour les
autres moyennes différence et sur
pécresse est ce que vous les comprenez
je les comprends parce que ce n'était
pas de l'argent pour eux comme ça
c'était un fonds d'investissement je
pourrais aussi voyez vous allez dire que
j'ai pas content le gouvernement réduit
les investissements dans les transports
remet tout en cause
moi je considère qu'un pays doit
investir donc je trouvais la région vous
vouliez vous vouliez supprimer les jeux
l'échelon régional oui je me souviens
j'ai alors à l'échelon de fusion de
départements et je pense qu'une france
de 70 départements serait plus efficace
que d'avoir les régions les départements
et la question sur les régions
rapidement donc elles ont raison à bâle
deux raisons c'est absurde
le problème du gouvernement sait que sa
politique aurait un sens si ils
favorisent l investissement productif en
france
en vérité ils baissent de très grandes
fortunes et il favorise pas l'irrigation
dont vous parliez qui pourrait être
intéressante
je suis pas hostile à une irrigation moi
je suis pas mélenchon comprenant ce que
vous croyez
très bien merci jean-francis qui rassure
et peut-être d'une certaine manière je
ne sais pas en tous les cas la suite de
l'émission tenant je crois pas mais avec
mes kms de public sénat on va parler
d'europe
[Musique]
enfin mickaël bon sens michel bonjour
bonsoir union alors de la sorbonne en
passant par l'acropole est ce que vous
diriez qu'emmanuel maquereau a enfin
donné un souffle nouveau à l'europe
je suis désolé de vous dire je savais
mon nom mais la question quand même mais
non mais parce que si emmanuel macron
avait fait ses discours et que par
exemple 18 septembre il avait dit
solennellement la france refuse
l'application du c'est à ce traité de
libre-échange totalement contradictoire
est d accord écologique de paris et qui
va détruire notre agriculture nos
terroirs et aggraver la crise climatique
alors là j'aurais dis bravo discours à
l'acropole prise de position ferme sur
le ceta bravo non non en fait le
problème des manuels macron c'est qui
fait de très beaux discours d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il a été apprenti comédien
ça se voit il a du talent mais le
problème c'est pas ça c'est la cohérence
pardonner mans entre les discours et les
actes et je vois deux actes majeurs
trois mêmes en europe qui m'inquiète
c'est l'application dès le 21 septembre
du c'est à ce fameux traité
libre-échange avec le canada
alors même que pendant la campagne
présidentielle j'avais été heureux
d'entendre monsieur macron dire je
revois ce dossier nous allons créer une
commission eux je serais prêt à ne pas
l'appliquer
la commission a été créée il a respecté
sa promesse sur ce point là pour le dire
mais la commission a rendu des
conclusions très défavorable aux états
et le gouvernement a dit ah bah je peux
plus rien faire on l'appliquent le 21
septembre musée du point d'eau comprenez
que les français qui avaient cru
monsieur macron pendant la campagne et
qui croyait qu'il allait changer les
choses
e soit un peu déçu mais quand tu parle
par exemple d'europe à plusieurs
vitesses quand il juge que l'europe est
trop faible tout ça mais en paroles
c'est ça va dans votre sens et attendait
dire que vous aimez prenait toute la
campagne mais oui mais j'aime et je suis
ravi qu'il le dise
bon le problème c'est pas qu'il sait
qu'il ne fait pas le problème de fond
c'est que des discours comme ça non non
il tort peut-être ce bras un peu à tort
rien du tout c'est plutôt elle qui lui
tend le bras
enfin c'est à dire le seul touché
aujourd'hui il est en iran avant même
qu'elle parle d'ailleurs on le voit sur
la sphère siemens est peut être un peu
fort non non vous savez la france c'est
une question de volonté aussi un moment
et sa victoire très large pouvait lui
permettre justement de revoir les choses
mais vous savez des discours comme ça on
en a entendu 50 depuis que je suis dans
la politique
jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande de grands discours pompeux pour
dire que l'europe c'est formidable on
entendu plein moi j'aurais aimé un
discours pratiques qui nous aurait
peut-être parler de coopération
industrielle silva par géricault mais
pas abba pire ah ben on va l'écouter sur
les vacances on va l'écouter sur la
défense vous allez vraiment les crocs
nîmes en l'écoutant l'écoutent
je propose ainsi à nos partenaires
d'accueillir dans nos armées nationales
et j'ouvre cette initiative dans les
armées françaises
des militaires venant de tous les pays
européens volontaires pour participer le
plus en amont possible à nos travaux
d'anticipation de renseignement de
planification et de soutien aux
opérations au début de la prochaine
décennie
l'europe devra ainsi être doté d'une
force commune d'intervention d'un budget
de défense commun et d'une doctrine
d'une doctrine commune pour agir ça ne
veut absolument rien aux rouges frappés
d'une seule voix ce nom mais ça ne veut
rien dire
tout ça est ridicule vous savez que
quand vous en voyez que je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
quand vous envoyer quelqu'un à la mort
un soldat c'est quelqu'un qui donne sa
vie pour la nation c'est pa 28 pays
avec 28 politique étrangère différentes
souvenez vous de l'affairé irakienne qui
vont le faire
on ne prendra jamais la question de la
défense nationale comme ça sauf à
considérer qu'il ya plus qu'un pays
une élection ce qui n'est pas le cas
tout ça c'est c'est pour amuser la
galerie c'est n'importe quoi
la vraie question sur la d
ans c'est de bâtir des coopérations
industrielles c'est d'éviter par exemple
que les polonais achète des avions
américains ce qui continue à faire c'est
aussi de les allemands leaders bien
évidemment des livres à cenon et
coopération déjà déjà si on pouvait au
moins fabriquer ensemble sur une base
d'égalité correctement des armements
ça serait déjà un miracle est ce que
vous vous attendez attendez on en est
déjà très loin
alors vous savez actuellement la france
assure gratuitement la sécurité au mali
d'accord et vous venez et attendait et
et j'aimerais entendu le retirer nos
formes non mais si je peux finir j'ai
pas entendu monsieur macron qu'avoir été
une discussion pratique dire voilà nos
amis doivent payer une partie puisque
nous assurons la sécurité de nos amis
européens
on pourrait très bien imaginer des
coopérations concrètes non on est dans
ce que j'appelle le vent en brasse de
l'air et c'est tellement loin de la
réalité des choses
moi je que je souhaite c'est une europe
des projets est ce que vous imaginez des
militaires d'autres pays comme possédant
l'armé ayant servi je vais vous donner
un exemple du filet à 9h mêmes et ça
c'est du cinéma pour amuser la
proposition concrète m'écouter arrêtez
vous êtes suffisamment intelligents pour
savoir ce n'est pas concret parce que je
prends un exemple vous croyez que tel
soldats de tels pays acceptera par
exemple de mourir au mali si c'est le
président français qui est engagée qui a
pas l'accord du président d'autres pays
et s'il n'ya pas l'accord du président
du troisième pays au plein milieu d'une
opération va retirer le soldat on avance
au pouvoir était l'ailé les balivernes
s'il vous plaît c'est pas sérieux la
commission européenne est prête à revoir
la libre circulation ça c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait dans votre sens en
cas de menaces nous pourrons donc
rétablir les contrôles aux frontières
jusqu'à trois ans visiblement c'est ce
que la commission européenne vous dites
bravo la commission mais heureusement qu
enfin il ya un peu de d'ouverture des
yeux mais moi je ne veux pas trois ans
je veux qu'on contrôle aux frontières et
je ne veux pas un cas non pourquoi je
vous dire pourquoi parce que on a
l'autorisation dé contrôler mais il faut
se donner les moyens mais contrôlé et
aujourd'hui vous le savez très bien
on n'a pas suffisamment de police
l'air et des frontières de force
militaire de forme ovale de gendarmerie
on va le faire mais pas assez vite c'est
urgent et j'avais proposé pendant la
présidentielle un plan très équilibré
très sérieux pour pouvoir le faire
j'ajoute parallèlement que si on veut le
faire cesser cette invasion migratoire
qui a dans notre sur notre continent
il va falloir au plus vite maintenant
que les affaires syriennes se règle
enfin que les syriens qui sont venus en
europe puissent repartir en syrie moi je
considère qu a aucune raison que les
réfugiés restent en europe
ils doivent repartir en syrie à partir
du moment où la paire revient en syrie
et donc on est très loin du compte
il faut réorganiser nos frontières il
faut un vrai plan d' aide à l'afrique
il faut stabiliser notre flanc sud il ya
une bonne chose qu'a fait emmanuel
macron voyez c'est de réunir les deux
interlocuteurs
les deux chefs d'état si on peut dire
pas très précis ce que je dis là mais
l'un est un chef d'état officielle
l'autre libyen parce que la stabilité de
la libye est vital
si on veut contrôler les frontières donc
sur le plan international elle voulu
trouver quand même qu'elle se suivent
sur ce point là sur ce point là je suis
d'accord je le dis sur ce point là c'est
fondamental mais on est très loin du
compte parce qu'il faut contrôler nos
frontières il faut détruire les barques
des passeurs avant bien évidemment
qu'ils prennent des migrants et il faut
organiser la l'europe pour être
magnifique
un vrai développement en afrique par un
plan marshall vis-à-vis de l'afrique du
nord qui devrait être la première
ambition européenne avant tout le reste
sur le plan des frontières sur la
question que je vous pose un homme
estimé que la chaine game c'est mort est
repéré mais bien évidemment schengen est
mort et enterré
sauf qu'on en tirera des leçons on n'en
tire pas suffisamment les leçons nous
mêmes ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
faut pas organiser aux frontières de
l'europe des coopérations
je ne suis pas du tout hostile moi j'ai
un triptyque très simples frontières
nationales coopération européenne aux
frontières européennes notamment pour
détruire les passeurs et puis
développement de l'afrique
et là l'europe peut jouer un rôle euh
vous savez l'enjeu pour demain c'est la
bonne articulation entre la nation et
l'europe
c'est pas d'être anti européen mais
c'est pas non plus de jeter la nation
comme dans le discours de monsieur mâcon
j'aimerais vous entendre comme votre
position sur le référendum
d'indépendance qui aura lieu ce week-end
en catalogne
c'est un dossier extrêmement difficile
parce que vous ne pouvez pas forcer une
région à rester dans un giron national
si elle ne le veut pas et en même temps
cela peut être vraiment l'explosion de
l'europe et l'arrivée vers un chaos
extrêmement grave est donc d'accord avec
manuel valls quand il dit que ce serait
la fin de l'europe
pas obligatoirement ça serait le début
de leurs hôtes allemands de l'europe des
régions et ce qui serait très dangereux
pour l'europe
donc je pense que il faut absolument
éviter cette séparation mais je ne pense
pas que le gouvernement espagnol et
était très malin c'est à dire c'est à
dire que je pense que les progrès qu'il
a est il a manqué de finesse et je pense
qu'on ne peut pas imposer à une région
de rester dans un giron national si elle
ne le veut plus et ce n'est pas en
mettant de l'huile sur le feu comme l'a
fait monsieur rajoy qu'on y arrivera et
la france qui soutient madrid est ce que
ça vous choque
non c'est normal que la norma
soutiennent madrid enfin va quand même
pas en plus
on pourrait mettre des avances ou je ne
sais pas d où je pense que c'est une
affaire suffisamment grave pour que
quelle que soit sa couleur politique on
est à des raisonnements d'homme d'état
merci michael dernière partie maintenant
de l'épreuve de vérité on va parler de
votre mouvement de son avenir des
alliances que vous imaginez présent
d'avoir scellé certaine aux
présidentielles inquirer que j'assume
qui est que vous assumez qui ont fait
scandale
y compris d'ailleurs dans votre parti et
c'est avec eux guillaume daudin de l'
agence france presse que nous parlons de
tout ça maintenant merci encore michael
il est prof de l'éviter bonsoir
guillaumin soir michel bonsoir monsieur
dupont-aignan l'art monsieur dowd 1
après sept
quelques mois après cette présidentielle
vous lancer une plateforme les amours de
la france on voulait vous demander avec
qui vous allez poursuivre cette aventure
politique que j'avais entamé vous avez
vous êtes allés avec marine le pen
j'ai soutenu au second tour et je ne
regrette pas un instant parce que j'ai
voulu casser ce piège de françois
mitterrand qui fait que les lecteurs
patriotes et disons de droite au delà de
la droite même est éternellement
minoritaires parce que on a inventé une
coupure symbolique qui peut être étaient
légitimes du temps que jean marie le pen
parce que je n'aurais jamais soutenu
jean marie le pen et vous le savez bien
mais qui n'est plus légitime du temps de
marine le pen puisque ce n'est pas le
même parti et pas le même programme
cela n'a pas abouti elle n'a pas gagné
l'élection vous l'avez constaté il et je
maintiens que les électeurs que je
croise qui votent parfois front national
parfois debout la france parfois
républicains sont très proches et en ont
assez d'avoir des dirigeants qui sont
artificiellement séparer alors juste et
donc toute l'idée que j'ai c'est avec
une grande plateforme participative
internet que nous lancerons le 25
octobre
dalé bâtir avec les français les
français qui aiment la france qui ne
veulent pas de cette société de l'argent
roi
dalé bâtir le programme comme un futur
de gouvernement parce qu'en fait j'ai
compris un truc alors intégrer mon
prénom se déchiraient sur des points
absurde alors qu'ils avaient 90 pour
l'enquêté en commun entre l'électeur
républicain électeurs du front ce que
vous pensez que vous allez réussir à
faire un programme commun à cinq ans
d'une élection présidentielle
mais on a le temps déjà de parcourir la
france de faire des réunions de passe et
j'allais dire sous la vague des
appareils politiques qui chacun soit à
chaleur boutiques orange âge et ma
boutique front national j'ai ma boutique
debout la france où j'ai ma boutique si
quelqu'un la vôtre on va en parler mais
vous savez le slogan de notre plateforme
internet c'est le pays avant les parties
du corps
si les leaders parce qu'on a quand même
perdu les élections vous comme s'en
souvenir
si les leaders des républicains de ceux
qui restent parce que les autres ils
vont et c'est parce qu'ils sont d'accord
ils vont avec monsieur macro libre à eux
si les leaders des républicains de
debout la france et du front national ne
sont pas capables de comprendre qu'il
faut réfléchir ensemble à l'avenir
et bien moi je vous prédis que la france
va coincer entre macro et mêlant alors à
l'enjeu leur a laissé la france otages
d'un conflit mélenchon macron qui
aboutirent à la ruine du pays quel que
soit le président attendait comme vous
dites les leaders des républicains en
nouant comprend évidemment laurent
wauquiez vous miser à fond sur laurent
wauquiez je le redis ici dans la
fondation une famille c'est que je
constate c'est que j'ai beaucoup d'élus
républicains qui m'appelle en ce moment
et qui me dit c'est bien ce que tu fais
on pourra en parler après l'élection du
président et vas-y parce que il va
falloir les secouer nos chefs mais voilà
ce qu est léger on va secouer les chefs
par la base vous on va aller à la
rencontre des électeurs on va aller dans
toutes les villes de france avec cette
plateforme on va dire aux électeurs
s'ils ensemble on travaillait et on va
commencer sur du concret ouais quel
programme pour revaloriser le travail
quel programme pour relancer notre pays
ça fait dix ans que vous dites que les
républicains ex ump sont des adorateurs
de l'union européenne en est ce là ils
ont pas l'autre malgré ses formes
hilarant wauquiez on peut travailler
avec lui il est il qu'ils aient dupont
aignan compagnie laurent wauquiez c'est
laurent wauquiez bon mais moi je
m'adresse pas laurent wauquiez là je
m'adresse
à tous les dirigeants qui n'étaient pas
compatibles son parti et que c'est mal
je vous dis c'est qu'il ya reprenons à
la base il y à une révolution politique
en france qu'a fait emmanuel macron je
le conteste je suis en désaccord complet
avec ses choix mais je reconnais qu'il a
réuni la gauche de gouvernement et la
droite de gouvernement qui faisait la
même politique depuis 20 ans à tour de
rôle ils ont enfin compris qu'ils
étaient pareilles edouard philippe haeuw
colons en fait c'est la même eh bien à
partir du moment où les mondialistes les
européistes les fédéralistes son
ensemble il est normal que ceux qui
défendent une certaine idée de la france
une certaine idée des valeurs se
regroupent aussi mais donc laurent
wauquiez oui non en fait il partie de
mes cils venir israël bienvenus j'ai le
sentiment qu'il hésite
eh bien je vais m'adresser pas laurent
wauquiez parce que j'ai jamais vu un
chef de parti qui en général voulait
comment dire libérer les choses on va
passer sur le terrain il n'a pas l'air
d'hésiter dans sa campagne dans son
positionnement non il le sait vraiment
une droite qui qui qui savent plus qui
s'affirme mais en même temps il dit je
veux pas travailler avec les autres or
si vous croyez et c'est ce que je vais
leur répéter à la sab le mans mais si on
est très fort sur le terrain
ils entendront le message des électeurs
l'union des électeurs ils l'entendront
je vais leur expliquer vous et je le dis
à marine le pen comme à wauquiez comme à
tout le monde je leur dis si vous pensez
qu'il faut penser maintenant à 2022 vous
vous trompez personne ne sait qui sera
en position 2022 et si chacun repart
dans sa roue comme l'amstel dans sa roue
qui pédalent marine le pen wauquiez mois
et des autres eh bien vous assisterez à
la fin de la france entre mélenchon et
makro donc on a une responsabilité
historique de repartir à la base sur le
terrain et je crois aux nouvelles
technologies je crois que cette
plateforme internet elle va
révolutionner la politique comment
marche a révolutionné la gauche et le
centre alors et on va essayer de
bousculer les choses et responsabilité
historique c'est ce qui vous fait
endosser le casque bleu en allant
déjeuner la semaine dernière avec marine
le pen avec florian philippot
aujourd'hui avec nicolas bellet vous
essayer de réconcilier le
le faut je n'ai pas cette prétention
c'est pas ma famille politique
contrairement à ce qu'a dit la presse
dans l'entre-deux-tours je n'ai pas
rejoint le front national je reste
indépendant debout la france reste un
parti indépendant et je n'ai jamais
voulu fusionner les parties d'accord en
revanche j'estime qu'au moment je veut
unir tout le monde c'est pas la peine de
s'envoyer des paquets les uns les autres
et quand je vois des gens qui ont
travaillé ensemble pendant des années se
désunir
j'essaye de comprendre mais c'est ce qui
se passe aussi à ce qui s'est passé à
debout la france vous prétendez faire le
rassemblement des engins et à debout la
france 200 résidents et père du web les
responsables savez j'ai jamais où on n'a
jamais autant d'adhérents on a eu deux
mille cinq cents adhérents
supplémentaires en un mois
parce que les gens ont compris et c'est
intéressant il vient à la fois du front
national est à la fois des républicains
mais l'enjeu c'est pas de goût la france
l'enjeu c'est pas le front national
l'enjeu c'est pas les républicains
l'enjeu c'est la france est ce qu'on est
capable d'avoir un projet alternatif à
sa macron parce que tout à l'heure
monsieur pécresse pouvait avoir raison
sur un point ils disaient vous êtes
contre il a raison je suis contre mais
l'enjeu c'est pas d'être contre
l'enjeu c'est d'être capable de proposer
une alternative et je vais vous de faire
une confidence
pendant cet été j'ai essayé de réfléchir
à l'échec une second tour et je pense
que certains ont imputé sa au débat de
marine le pen vraiment j'en doute mais
je pense que c'est plus profond je pense
qu'en vérité les français n'avaient pas
soif de macron simplement les
propositions alternatives ne les ont pas
convaincus c'est à dire qu'ils ont voté
par défaut est donc l'enjeu c'est pas de
critiquer macron l'enjeu c'est proposer
un beau projet pour la france
il rassure il ya aussi une question
assure une alliance à droite de la
droite ça peut faire 50 % des électeurs
mais il s'agit pas de faire la droite de
la droite
les amoureux de la france s'adresse pas
qu'aux gens de droite mais d'abord si on
pouvait réunifier les patriotes dit de
droite mais est patriote c'est pas
simplement être de droite il ya des
patriotes à gauche hum hum en revanche
ça sera pas d'extrême gauche de
mélenchon parce que je pense pas qu'on
puisse aller totalement à gauche
totalement à droite je pense qu'il faut
rassembler déjà les gens qui pensent
pareil ça serait déjà pas mal les gens
qui pensent pareil alors petit deux
petites questions très rapide donc vous
êtes monsanto est tombé dont je le
remets vous vous sentez très pro
de marine le pen mais j'ai pas aimé son
jeu sous pas de marina de van est
soutenue au second tout d'accord parce
qu'entre malgrange attendait entre
macron et le pen je pensais qu'il valait
mieux avec le programme que j'avais
négocié avec elle qu'il fallait mieux ce
programme là et je pense que les
français vont commencer à comprendre
vous vous sentez très proche de laurent
wauquiez aussi j'ai pas me sentir proche
et si je voudrais préciser moi je fais
pas de politique je vous faire entendre
quelqu'un sait si vous étiez c'est un
coup de com mais non ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que c'est on s'en fout que je
sois proche de madame le pen ou de
monsieur wauquiez de tartempion qu'est
ce qui compte c'est la capacité à faire
des réformes en france et à sauve
accueilli attention fairy m'intéresse
c'est le programme que c'est pas les
personnalités je vais vous faire écouter
florian philippot qui lui il le dit il
se sent très proche de vabres c'est
sûrement dupont aignan c'est autre chose
là on peut faire un bout de chemin
ensemble parce que politiquement nous
sommes très proches on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout mais nous sommes très
proches
lui et moi et nous sommes gaulliste
c'est déjà très bien et puis nous avons
tous les deux cette même vision d'un
rassemblement nécessaire
les forces patriotiques et des patriotes
français d'où qu'ils viennent de pour
l'emporter discours se ressemble on a
l'impression voilà que florian philippot
fait du nicolas dupont aignan en sachant
ou sans le savoir et qu'elle dit il est
en train de parler du fn en disant je
veux faire le fn mais sans ses excès
c'est un peu ce que vous avez image est
toujours saisi la dernière année mais
j'aime à ce qui est curieux c'est que
j'ai jamais changé j'ai toujours depuis
philippe séguin j'ai considéré que la
droite française avait oublié la nation
s'est fourvoyé dans cette mauvaise
europe parce qu'il a une belle europe à
construire et que la gauche française a
oublié le peuple et s'est fourvoyé dans
cette mauvaise europe on a une chance
historique c'est qu'ils sont tous mis
ensemble ils vont sombrer ensemble avec
macron mais une sombrerons et les
français abandonneront macron et tout
cet aéropage qu'elle gouvernait depuis
20 ans fait même s'ils ont rajeuni que
si on est capable de présenter un beau
projet alternatif et les français sont
très sages
monsieur dowd 1 ils sont
h ils veulent savoir comment on va gérer
l'europe ils veulent savoir comment va
défendre nos pme relocaliser ils veulent
savoir comment va sauver l'hôpital
et c'est parce qu'on n'a pas été capable
de les convaincre qu'on a perdu alors
entonné d'ailleurs il faut en tirer les
leçons
il ya une chose que des leçons de ce
philippot et d'autres veulent le faire
plus on sera nombreux plus on rassurera
les français est d'abord mettons nous
d'accord sur ce programme commun et
c'est tout l'enjeu des amoureux de la
france point fr qui sera lancé le 25
octobre
parce que ça va permettre de bousculer
les nattes alors dites-moi florian
philippot dit aussi ceux ci il dit que
son départ marque finalement pour le
front national
retour ses vieux démons du parti
d'extrême droite c'est pas votre vision
alors si on vous suit bien et moi
attendait f1 ne renoue pas j'ai le
maillot du monde j'ai pas été comme
monsieur philippe aux 6 ans et 7 ans je
sais pas combien d'années aurait fait 10
ans je n'ai jamais été au fn donc c'est
lui qui connaît le fn pour autant
attention à ces paroles qui
d'anticipation moi je fais pas de la
politique par anticipation
je constate aujourd'hui que en tout cas
le fn tel qu'il est aujourd'hui de
marine le pen et qui a été d'ailleurs
dédiaboliser avec le concours de florian
philippot me paraît tout à fait comment
dire capable d'évoluer dans le bon sens
pour les années à venir mais j'insiste
sur un point c'est que si c'est pour
reprendre le même programme qu'en 2017
ça ne marchera pas je pense que le fn
doit faire un pas vers l'est républicain
je pense que les républicains peuvent
faire un pas parce que sinon si personne
ne fait de pas encore une fois on sera
dans les caricatures des caricatures
donc la question n'est pas de savoir
diabolisation dédiabolisation la
question est de savoir quel est le beau
projet qui peut sortir la france du
pétrin
quel est le beau projet qui peut
permettre de re localiser deux millions
d'emplois
quel est le beau projet qui peut
permettre de concilier liberté et
sécurité pour l'un des vrais y est ce
l'une des grandes questions qui divisent
mais ce ne sont pas ceux viendra le fn
comme je ne sais pas ce que deviendra
des républicains l'une des grandes et je
sais ce qu'ils disent
son la région sera la dernière question
ça sera la der à question dans ces gens
à qui vous voulez parler c'est justement
la place de la sortie de l'euro oui
florian philippot en fait une ligne
rouge
vous avez influer sur le programme du
front pour que ça soit moins pressés one
d accord que j'avais florian philippot
et je suis convaincu qu'à partir du
moment où les français ne veulent pas
sortir de l'euro ça sert à rien de dire
il faut sortir de l'euro si les français
ne veulent pas et je suis convaincu que
à mesure que le temps passe il ya des
moyens de faire évoluer la politique
monétaire notamment le qui peuvent être
intéressants il faut qu'on travaille
et moi je veux préparer cette
plate-forme commune pour dans un an
qu'on soit prêts ou deux ans une vraie
plateforme commune mais qui part de la
base provient pas les leaders qui l'a
fait on a compris les lecteurs tj on a
compris votre les élections à la barre
et par une stratégie numérique on a même
noté la date et octobre
dialogues bien simplement sur internet
merci nicolas merci à vous merci
beaucoup guillaume on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine est notre invité sur
la jean christophe cambadélis à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]